Wow the irony that the tragedy is that's
what religion is supposed to be it's
supposed to teach us the difference
between good and evil and yet it's been
used so frequently or abused for
separation for 8/4 rationalizing
so much art we i I'm one of those who
believes that you know there needs to be
a separation between religion and and
and state and and yet at the same time
if the spirit of love which comes from
religion doesn't inspire our leadership
it could be very very very dangerous
encounter for death so it's a very
difficult balance there look you have
you have Iran it's quote/unquote a
religious country look how much hate
there is there in Israel there's a lot
of religion it hasn't resolved all the
problems in our country we're struggling
with this some of that some of the most
some of the most okay I'm trying to find
for in the work
some of the most some of the most
polarizing elements in our society come
from religious leaders when I think to
the Jews to read what we found out to
Billy Graham was an anti-semite it's
sort of so you know what's religion all
about here is the spiritual guide to so
many presidents here is the guy that
presidents would go for spiritual
counsel and advice and here we find out
he's just a pure simple ugly classic
anti-semite so how do you deal with that
I've been raised in faith
I'm amazed and faithless during the war
as a Catholic and then when I returned
to Judaism I've been raised in faith I
think it it has a role but frequently
it's abused it's abused by temporal
powers by political institutions for its
own benefit and sometimes it is seduced
by the political by them by the secular
I think I think history judgment is
still out whether the promise of the
faith and love and understanding and
sensitivity that religion promises is
maybe more counterproductive because
some religions teach exclusiveness I
think the most important element for
faith and religion to be positive
instrument and love is the difference
between a and thee as long as we teach
that we have the truth the only truth it
will only undermine understanding and
respect and love if we can teach that
all we do is have a truce I have a truth
you have a truth Catholics ever truth
Muslims have a truce it's their way to
salvation it's their way for their
people to achieve tranquility love
future whatever
you